hmm
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
and everything relating to the mcu and
right now we
finally have some movement in the marvel
cinematic universe
marvel studios is back at it filming the
falcon and the winter soldier as we
speak
last night we finally got an official
cast for
she-hulk jennifer walters and if you
missed that video i'll link it up above
but we
do finally have our she-hulk and it's
not allison brie
and then in the middle of not knowing if
we're actually going to be getting any
shows or movies in 2020
disney came out and announced that we
are in fact going to be getting the one
division series
this year in 2020 and to top it all off
production has re-begun for the loki
series
a series that people are very very
excited about especially if you consider
the fact that it's basically been
confirmed that kang the conqueror
is coming to the mcu in ant-man 3. and i
expect there to be some big connections
to kang
in the loki series to start it all off
but we have some great loki series news
today so we're going to break everything
down in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on anything relating to the mcu
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a thanos
funko pop
just subscribe like the video and leave
a comment down below so marvel seems to
be pushing
full steam ahead now with getting all of
their projects moving again
and thanks to a new mysterious photo
from atlanta
we have confirmation that the loki
series is about to resume
filming now before we get started a lot
of people have asked me about the
release date and apparently
from everything that i've heard so far
it's still set for a spring of 2021
release
now i want to say don't get your hopes
up because a lot of things have been
pushed back so far but disney is coming
out with one division
in december that means that they could
release the falcon in the winter soldier
in early 2021
and then in the spring of 2021 released
the loki series so it is possible
and apparently it is still marvel's plan
so that's some good news
and again thanks to this mysterious
photo that we got
we know that the set of the loki series
is being built right now
thanks to the instagram account atlanta
filming who has been fortunate enough to
leak
many things on the set of marvel studios
in the past
we can see that the set is currently
being built for the loki series now
unfortunately
what this could be right here is kind of
unknown it's a little bit of a mystery
but one thing that we do know that
marvel has confirmed is that the loki
series is going to be a
combination of sci-fi and fantasy now
the fantasy side is simply
going to come from the fact that loki is
an asgardian and he's also a sorcerer he
knows magic and he knows magic very well
his mother did a good job at teaching
him magic but we also have already kind
of seen the sci-fi version of the loki
series in the quick little teaser that
we got from marvel during the super bowl
i'm gonna burn this place to the ground
now most of you have probably seen this
before and have realized that on his
shirt it says tva which stands for the
time
variance authority these guys are
basically responsible for making sure
that nobody messes up
other timelines outside of their own so
essentially if you have one universe
affecting another
alternate universe the tva intervenes
and we know that loki is pretty much
going to be messing up timelines because
we saw him escape in avengers in-game
which created a new timeline and we know
from this teaser that loki is going to
be captured by the tva which brings us
to this photo
this photo looks like it's going to be
some sort of a building that looks
pretty
strong this could perhaps be a prison
where they're going to hold loki
now we know from some leaked set photos
that owen wilson is going to be in the
show and he's going to be a person that
is very high up in the tva
and we know that he's going to get loki
to actually help him so essentially loki
is going to be a member of the tva
at least temporarily so this photo could
also be a base
of the tva a headquarters in the comics
they are
a very very big group so they're going
to need a base
of operations and perhaps that's what
this photo is but unfortunately
like i said it's pretty mysterious and
right now kind of hard to tell but let
me know what you think that it might
possibly be
leave your best guess and thoughts in
the comments down below
don't forget to give the video a like
and subscribe so you stay up to date on
everything that is happening in the mcu
for other funko pop giveaways and live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof
you